then we're here today to talk about your
role in Game of Thrones a huge show now
first of all of course you joined a
little bit into the series didn't you so
what was it like joining a
well-established cast on such a massive
show as that absolutely terrifying and
and a short sentence yeah it was
terrifying but at the same time you know
it's a challenge and that's what I think
there were businesses about it's great
fun I was always nervous a lot because
people had a chance
dude in the first series and throughout
the second series to get to know each
other and get to know how they work well
together
and I didn't really have any time to do
that I was thrown in at the deep end
with a lot of quite high-octane action
stuff to learn not a lot of time to chat
so it was it was quite nerve-wracking
but that we seemed to pull it off so it
doesn't worry me so much anymore talking
about that a high octane action how do
you get yourself ready for stuff like
that mentally physically every way
push-ups push-ups angry death metal lots
and lots of that on music yeah I don't
know
I just have read this Clapton that's it
I'm not there the usual kind of stuff
yeah push ups a priceless I exercise get
the blood flow and get there Jalen up go
and stand on a high ledge and look down
get yourself pumped always go purple
whichever we can maintain other so
classic always but everybody has their
own their own technique I suppose yeah
tell me a little bit about getting into
that character of Podrick Payne
because obviously you've got the books
which I know you've read some of haven't
years while you've got that but outside
the books as well how do you kind of get
into the mentality of the character and
how you portray him on screen um to
start with that was I was mostly that
was just reading what was on the page
and the start of the stuff I shot was
there wasn't much to it was quite subtle
whatever but as the more detailed stuff
happened really I just spoke to David
and Dan and
the Peter because he said most of all
chatted about what what we thought the
scene was about and when it was going
tried several things out and then you
know now from when we went back to the
shoot series 3 I certainly found far
easier and far more natural because I'd
already had a successful season last
year so I felt that especially Peter
Lynch it almond myself worked together
quite a lot we we just started bounced
off each other and there wasn't any
hassle it was just fun of course you
mentioned Peter there's your squire to
his character aren't you in the show and
also Jerome Jerome Flynn those plates
bran what's it like working with those
guys what do they like when they're
offset what they're like when they're
working what's it like I won't say too
much of it with a lake when they said
there's no great gates the Peter of them
Pete others just as wetting and just
this clever and funny has Teddy Anna's
he's a lovely book in the same when she
dorms it on as as as a great book the
pair of them were just really welcoming
to me um which no not every actor or
group of actors with a done with a young
guy coming in with to all the guys who
had already worked together successfully
for a week whale and then I was sort of
thrown into the mix and they just they
were just so so happy for me to be there
and they we're just pals now it's just
for just friends it's like we can we
always go out for dinner or we go out
for a few drinks over of iron it's just
it's become I suppose the relationship
has become more natural because it's now
like that we are quite close from Iran
sure we spend quite a lot of time with
each other when were on set and even
when we're off we go out and do things
so they just they made it as easy as
they could for me which I'm very
grateful for I mentioned of course you a
young actor this is when you first
really really big roles isn't it you
know out there at a huge show is lots of
great actors in there what do you gain
do you feel for yourself as an actor
working with people like Peter and
Jerome oh um I've improved I don't know
how much but I haven't haven't they
match what they are doing or haven't
tried to match what they are doing on
screen it's just I remember the
the frosting I shot I had hardly
anything at the I think it was in series
two when Janice lent as exhaled ah
whatever and I just watched because I
was off for most of the scene and I just
watched with the Peter than were doing
and couldn't believe it couldn't believe
that so much could be done with eyes eye
contact faces just nothing hardly
anything but they were put across so
much and you know i I've just tried to
sort of met up what they've done and use
what they've taught me and yeah I think
I have improved quite a lot since since
working with them and it's the same with
working with any any experienced actors
that you learn far more from them then
you have AI really good from any book
car but anything like that because
you're you're just doing it what are you
enjoying about playing Podrick in
particular what things kind of do you
think oh yeah that's that's really good
part of that role I'm not used to
playing never saw quiet or anything and
quite the opposite usually so it's nice
to experiment with with what I was going
on behind the eyes and just we things
because is something I'd really had
never done before
at all I'd always been the other end of
the spectrum and you know having what
was a quite a big opportunity doing
something that you're not used to doing
it's just been great fun it's just been
you know I can a completely new road to
go down and I've I've loved that I've
loved it because you know if this is
what people get to normally for and this
is what I've at least comfortable doing
you know I'm hoping it's gonna be quite
a good scene
what do you think audiences were
enjoying about her drinking we're
tequila and I think I think they they
just think a lot of people think he's
quite cute
don't ask me and but yeah I think people
just like how innocent he is and how he
a lot the thing he appears to not really
have a clue about what's going on and
and he's got that whole starting side he
comes on he spells away and he does that
but at the end of the series he
he saves the big man's life so those the
the whole flipside and the best point in
the series people don't really know what
is about they've seen most of what
happens and the second series worth and
being nervous and shy not speaking much
and not being able to look at people and
twitch him and falling over and all that
kind of stuff and then he has the Hilo
moment he has a huge moment when he he
saves one of the central characters and
that's really how you leave him in the
second series so at this point he's a
bit of an enigma to people that haven't
read the books and and whatever so I
think people are quite interested in
what's to come and I think they also
like their the massive flap that he
seems to have in his personnel that you
know if somebody something that he cares
about is in danger you know not not that
we I'm not that we buy anymore I'm a
completely different person and it's I'd
tried to play with it as if it was an
instinct he doesn't know he'd done it
and it was just that was that was the
natural thing he doesn't have any
control over what he was doing and then
hjerson it was it as soon as it was done
it was back to being this never starting
child again you have read some of the
books what stage are you at with the
reading do you keep yourself back or do
you keep on top of where they are your
head even I read I read to these Shh
for crews after the first series was on
before I knew it was going to be on I
read up to that point and then when I
get cast I stopped reading so I've not
read the last one it's just as exciting
for you then it's my audience yeah I'd
rather I'd rather not read any more than
so if the show goes that far we were
past that point to see if because who
knows if I'll end up the same who knows
what what changes will happen but yeah
but I think they are great books and I
love reading them but I'm not gonna not
gonna go any further I don't think I'd
rather just go what's on the page what
are the other characters maybe you don't
work with you you enjoy watching
particularly on the show and also tell
me a bit about the locations you've been
filming in as well um my favorite
characters as Jimmy Lannister
just and what what what Nick does is
just just fantastic he's just a class
act I think reading the books I wasn't
really interested in Theon but seeing
what Alf dead with her in the second
series I just thought he was as energy
was incredible it was just so so
compelling to watch and calleth the
police virus just just great and he's
good at it fun to work with on say he's
always a good laugh yeah very very funny
very good guy but this is just lovely to
have the opportunities of Robshaw
doesn't work with these guys because you
pick up something new every time you
leave her everything you leave this at
and location-wise I got to go to Croatia
that's the other film which was just and
clear double we found that the
some our buddy and I think it's that
through sternal Arboretum and the bluff
like which is just a huge garden of
tropical flowers and AH it was just
incredible and we shot their air for
that for a few days and I also shot at
Fort st. Lawrence which was closed for
the day we just had flea none of this
ancient castle which sort of took my
breath away about because there's on the
battlements you can look out on at the
sea and see nothing for as long as you
can see and it was just I think that's
what helps what helps the shore develop
is the fact that they seem to find these
locations that look mythical they look
like they're they shouldn't belong on
earth they shouldn't belong and you know
the place that has airports and hotels
in forever they look like that should be
dragons flying about he said you're very
different obviously in real life and the
kind of characters you play to project
before but how do you think if you had
to step into his world tomorrow how do
you think you'd fur as a squire what's
up I suppose a discordant I suppose
that's that's all you can do
like I don't I don't find say about
getting on Geoffrey's bad side so I
imagine if I was and that environment I
would just so I do I could but I
probably wouldn't be quite as quiet I
would maybe be a little cheeky and that
would probably save me quite badly but
make it as far as you have already Oh
probably not
why not and the costumes talking about
the kind of clothes he was in the life
that he lives what's it like wearing
those costumes and particularly in light
you talking about the heat there in
Croatia as well well they are fantastic
costumes and they they help me scent
like just adapt and getting involved
straight away because they are so
detailed you look at costumes they have
you know sketching patterns you've never
really seen before they have said use of
all these places that don't really come
up and ashore but somebody will see them
and it looks like looks like it's
something to do with something else that
you make find out about and the only the
only issue for me in Croatia was the
heat because I've got so many layers on
that I was just and I wasn't Pleasant it
was not pleasant I thought but them's
the brakes you know I'm working on Game
of Thrones so they don't really care
from if I'm winning five layers or 50
layers or still there what do you do
then at the end of the day when you've
been on the set in those clothes have
any great day you know doing some great
scenes but then it had you unwind when
you finish filming um
one glass of milk and I've got a bed
straight yeah no really and which and
they said we swam quite a lot and we ate
a lot a lot yeah it was just we started
made the most of the time we went out
and the same in Belfast as great food in
Belfast and usually bumpin a couple of
people that are on the shore doing a
different a different storyline get a
couple of drinks for them and then be
sensible have an early night and look
great for tomorrow tell me a little bit
about filming in Belfast as well what's
that been
for you well that's sort of that's my
hobby thats about the vast majority of
my stuff is taking place and I just love
that I think it's a great phone we saw
I've stay quite central and and got the
same place it's quite a lot but it's
just it's very like Glasgow and that's
where I was born
that's like on a grad that's the same
kind that people are there I just I love
it I love the energy I love the vibe but
just I think it's a great thing
great food great drink nice people what
more do you want
yeah hopefully you're gonna be in the
show for very much longer obviously
we're all hoping that what do you think
fans are going to be surprised by or can
they look forward to in the future from
the show whether they've read the books
or not more of the same but just just
exactly what people I want you really
that's all I can say this last year has
been play exciting and we're all but I
really really really hoping that it's
going to continue the success because
it's a happy Shore everybody loves
working on it as that's doing well it's
well written it's just beautifully put
together very well acted so yeah we're
just we're just hoping that you guys
enjoy watching it as much as we've
enjoyed making it and you're looking
forward yourself to kind of reading more
of the books as well as you kind of
progress with the show I am looking
forward to getting to the stage what I
feel comfortable reading the book but
the wanted to skip ahead any further I'm
looking forward to that stage but I
don't know I don't know by that point
who knows who knows we'll all be in the
show who knows what may be happening in
future after Game of Thrones but after
eventually finishes in the many many
many seasons times what would you like
to be doing I'll probably retire yeah
but it'd be quite old by then weren't
you easy you know just one glass and
I'll go ahead and now I'd just I
I'm not somebody who's hell-bent on
going Hollywood
and I would just like to keep working on
on good things for good people that's
what I've always found most enjoyable as
working on a great project something he
can really get involved them and that's
that's the beauty of Thrones it's not
only a huge success and back budget
massive viewership it's well written and
that's it's just that's something else
when you you can look at a script and
god geez that's that's I can do
something with that assembly I can do
something good with that so it's just
that's a pleasure and it makes it so so
much easier when it's handed tea on a
plate really yeah we look forward to
lots more seasons with Game of Thrones
and seeing what you're doing after that
as well yes
you